all right uh okay well apparently our
next guest just walked in the door
that's how it goes here with New York
traffic I guess nothing like leaving it
to the last minute you can find his
stand-up dates at John Doerr com next
week you can see him in the Broadway
show Hercules the musical please welcome
John Doerr
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm embarrassed I I'm clearly trying to
fit too much into my days it's true what
Conan's head next week I am starring in
Hercules musical I play the role of a
centaur
a mythical creature Greek mythology and
today we had a dress rehearsal i don't
went a little late and i did not have
time to change getting in and out of
that uber was a nightmare I'll tell you
that much
my ratings gonna plummet guaranteed and
I'm embarrassed I feel terrible I feel
bad for Conan I feel bad for you people
the viewers at home I mean I'm supposed
to tell jokes and this is going to be
distracting so if there's any way you
guys could just maybe maybe not focus on
how I look and just pay attention to
what I'm saying I think everything will
work out what do you say thank you right
let's have some fun here we are at the
Apollo New York
oh yeah there we go joke one you know
there was a time in my life when I
started hanging around the wrong crowd
and then one day I just realized wait a
minute I don't recognize any of these
people I have literally been hanging
around with the wrong crowd how long's
this been going on
but eventually I started hanging around
the right crowd and we did a lot of
drugs and we shop lifted so yeah see
that joke usually gets an applause break
but I feel like the outfit oh don't
please if it's not sincere you know what
maybe I'm just gonna skip the jokes cuz
this is too distracting and Conan did
promise me that I'd be able to premiere
a song from Hercules a musical so yeah
you don't want I don't do that
Jimmy whenever you're ready
[Music]
Oh Hercules we need you here come down
from Mount Olympus Oh Hercules no one
thinks you're weird
come down from us Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I bet you think I'm embarrassed I bet
you think I'm humiliated but I'm not
because it's not what you think
that wasn't urine mm-hmm that's right
it's my new energy drink integrity
integrity is something I got plenty of
it's from the makers of the all that top
hat chicken cooker oven hat when you're
trying to squeeze too much into your day
I suggest you try integrity no no don't
John let me get this straight I give you
a chance to do stand-up at the Apollo
Theater
thank you which is a great honor yes and
you use it to do this stupid commercial
this is disgraceful and you have no
integrity you work for me
seriously this is unacceptable you
arrive late you look like a fool you
look ridiculous I'm sorry you know what
he's right
Conan's right you're always right no I
did arrive late and that's on me and I
did abuse my power to promote this and I
do look ridiculous I'm not even I'll
just take this off you don't have to
take it off now you can leave it on it
looks ridiculous it's coming off no
don't please don't no one wants to see
it sound except you should go alright
you go
[Applause]
Gondor
going to do
you